doch wir den präsentiert forum bot
[Musik]
vermehrtes tagungsmarkt ist kein symbol
franken
ich weiß noch nichts vom hormon spitze
des so wie es trainer ist eine dichte
bei uns besonders ist die zeit senioren
bonitätswächter bauernhaus und am anfang
bis zu ganzen liga boomt gerade seine
streiche da vinci das wachstum geworden
macht vielleicht mal vor
wie sagst und nicht über 60 jahren
hätten gezeigt dass es frieden hätten
der sechste stolz und gebaut wenn jetzt
ist an urlaub nicht dass ich sie wegen
zu wenig gebaut und so ist klar solange
libor als nick als mal dass ich alles
was ich wollte sagt ja die zeiten
wirtschaftlich war wird es frieden
braucht
[Musik]
warum
die machte das jetzt nach
eine begangene durstigen könnte wenn du
als das was die chance alles vorher
[Musik]
nicht was da möglich sind um das am 20
da wollten wir nach übergriff warum das
so landwirt hat ich wünsche mir dass das
was für frierende passiert sonst
riskiere vorher den orbit rück sowie der
schulzeit tätigkeit nichts wenn ich
zwölf werde dazu wird da sie das
gefunden hat aber ich habe ja gar nicht
getraut worden sei und man ist eben
verstärkt mit umgelegt
[Musik]
nehmen wir das ksk
trans menschen sind menschen bei denen
das bei der geburt zugewiesene und das
gefühlte geschlecht nicht übereinstimmen
trans menschen sind überzeugt was ihre
identität ausmacht ist die seele nicht
der körper wenn jetzt einfach so noch
vorgesetzte
vielmehr muss kräftemäßig magie bewegt
medien als frau innerlich hat sich
natürlich auch einiges an verhandelt das
als frau bin ich extrem nachtragend sie
hat probleme
okay was ist mit hormonen amt in der
hülle
ich danke ich bin extrem viel härter
wurden bereits linksextreme verfahren
bei der beprobung pro bahn
dann muss ich sagen alle mannschaften
also als frau hat die deutschlandcard ok
hilft nur eins ist die die lage heißt
ihr werk ausgesucht also monaco
trotz dass die minimal music award ist
eine komponente wo du immer ein
biologisch immer wir stellen das wasser
reichen
und dank dass ich halt aus wo du dennoch
strebt norbert sie wollte dass man
irgendwo und märz mit sichtbar machen
und trotzdem wird jeden tag ein traum
sei jetzt operationsnarbe wo die drei
erinnert und eigentlich danken
wieso sind sie da und man ist ein sieg
würde dann zu mindern geschichte danke
schlimmste was man kannte sich seit 9
steigen
[Musik]
nico gaspari ist einer von geschätzten
40.000 trans menschen in der schweiz
längst nicht alle gehen den selben weg
wie nico über eine hormonbehandlung eine
namensänderung und eine operative
geschlechts angleichung diesen weg haben
hierzulande bisher nur wenige tausend
auf sich genommen
[Musik]
ich bin vor dem großen china
wenn man rehna und simoncelli in die
augen blickt sieht man zwei geschwister
die sich sehr ähnlich sehen
sie sind eineiige zwillinge doch sie
waren nicht immer bruder und schwester
simon und rena sind als eineiige
zwillingsschwester zur welt gekommen und
aufgezogen worden
und da praktischer geworden dass auf dem
first edition ihr kleid will und ich
[Gelächter]
habe immer mit mario oder wunsch da und
da hat es ist ein leidlich sie und es
wird einfach mitmachen ist einfach also
ich und so denkt so nicht ob ich mir
schnell stammt liegt auch mir nicht mit
statistiken und so einfach ist wie es
aussieht zeigt auf das einzel haben also
vor allem der oberstufe vorbild und
einen stammhalter aber auch ich kann in
der oberstufe mal verschlagen
das einfach nicht ist nicht damit dass
er sich jetzt ändern denn dann das macht
ja wirklich mal von ganz klar seinen
vorschlag mit 32 nationen in
kempfenhausen im nachhinein leid aber
ich will jetzt mit dem um und ist das
für dich
schlimmer noch es pausenlos so sind ist
schwer zu glauben das nicht sie dass sie
irgendwie einfach alle normal sind auch
wenn ich an das spiel mit sicherheit
kein grund zum wechseln und verbringen
innerlich scheint ist wenn er dort tätig
sind
das war ein optimales abo sex jeder
mensch so nah war ich am schluss eine
verständliche und hätte politiker dabei
setzen deswegen in gruppen oder so
auch karoline schulz wurde in der
schulzeit gemobbt sie war damals unter
ihrem buben nahmen weder bei den jungs
noch bei den mädchen beliebt in den 70er
jahren gab es kaum informationen über
transit entität karolines eltern konnten
nicht ahnen dass ihr kind zwar für sie
als junge geboren war sich aber schon
immer als mädchen fühlte
caroline ist zu einer
klassenzusammenkunft eingeladen die alle
zehn jahre in bern stattfindet die
ehemaligen klassen mitglieder wissen
zwar dass caroline seit zwei jahren als
frau lebt sie haben ihren alten
schulkameraden aber noch ganz anders in
erinnerung
[Musik]
die großen fotos sind die neugier ist
groß alle wollen von caroline wissen wie
es damals für sie war schon immer eine
spezielle kategorie kanzel und opel sind
sich vorstand noch hat es nur michaels
geht es doch gar nicht
bis dahin katholischer geo fertigen wir
als mächtiger der letzte hort ist mit
typisch wolle möglichst überhaupt nur
halbwegs optimistisch auch wenn man
genau ist das amerikanisch war knapp
ich bin eben nie diesen kostenblock was
der einheitlichkeit und nachbereitung
der ganze herziger burg oder aber du
hast die gar nicht getraut das aber da
ist dann sind so fest gefügt ab du hast
ja niemand getraut die betreuungsquote
vor
doch gar nicht nico gaspari arbeitet als
pflegefachkraft in einem pflegeheim in
burgdorf bis vor kurzem wusste hier
niemand dass nico einmal als frau lebte
er wollte seine geschichte am
arbeitsplatz nicht zum thema machen
daher passen die apbetro dazu verlockend
und halte zugleich so präsentiert sich
rechtlich gesehen ist micro ein mann
er muss seine trans and i tät nicht
offenlegen als er sich einem der
mitarbeiter doch anvertraute kam die
sache raus und nikos geheimnis
verbreitete sich wie ein lauffeuer
das ist riesig und ethisch
gedankenspiele job los
und 2 für licht ob aufgrund einer trans
identität ist als die c
und vom in der spinnerei sehr viel
menschlichkeit erfahren wie sich das
thema sich nichts oktober gegen mittlere
meister und ich beginne jetzt noch
akzeptiert dass die kunden schließt aber
das war uns erfolgreich im gleichen boot
wie du mit ihnen mit dem rückweg hatten
ihm schlecht ging ja quasi als diskreten
umweltanwaltschaft für die ganze dass
ich sehr froh dass ich gerade gesagt du
hast du nie
[Musik]
trans frauen haben es in der arbeitswelt
oft schwerer als trans männer ihre trans
identität ist oft sichtbarer und
auffälliger karoline schulz ist seit
drei jahren arbeitslos nach einem
arbeitsunfall am fuß verlor sie damals
im beruf noch nicht geoutet ihre stelle
mit der tradition dem übergang vom leben
in einem geschlecht zum anderen wurde
die arbeitssuche nicht einfacher
im gegenteil meistens scheitert es
bereits nach dem ersten
einstellungsgespräch
[Musik]
der 25 jährige simon fällt in der
speditionsbranche nicht weiter auf
trotzdem hat er seine vorgesetzten von
anfang an über seine tradition in
kenntnis gesetzt der chef nahm's locker
meint simon
solange die ware sicher von a nach b
transportiert wird sei ihm egal ob eine
frau oder ein mann hinter dem steuer
säße
mehr
mich haben eine frau im job könnte ich
mich gar nicht integrieren und sich so
mit frauen zusammen aber man hat ihre
extrem ins andere extrem ins grundbuch
klar da ich da und so ist so unfertig
und dem ja das so gemacht und den anders
denkt da wie hat er so gemacht daher
muss es so machen frauen sprints ich bin
ja nicht aber für noch bei dem man
einfach wohl
[Musik]
nico gasbarri trifft sich mit einem
jüngeren trans man zum
erfahrungsaustausch macht wie zeigt sich
krass und 348 im hagen ist lehrer an
einer schule in sankt gallen wo bis vor
kurzem noch als frau unterrichtet hat
mit den hormonen ist tims stimme tiefer
geworden auch der bart beginnt zu
wachsen
bald möchte er sich auch einer
operativen geschlechts angleichung
unterziehen
ihr macht gern und ohne drama die falle
plastikröhre dass das drucken
vereinssport gehabt aber ich denke was
im genitalbereich in grenzen wie der
daytona dan coats wie das kloster habe
gründe jetzt für mich noch 70 oder
einander die lösung gefunden
das ist peter g t pt hypothese dass das
silikon keine tolle form macht es oft
aus deutschland ja noch werden
problematisch wird das macht dann meinem
fuß kann kann er problematiken ja ich
habe mir selbst risiko aufgrund unserer
operation wurde zwar sind alle dienste
ukraine stimmt das wird uns wohl fühlen
was ist mir die gesundheit anderer
unterricht ab
ein passant init untersuchungs und warum
für mich mit der gesellschaft sowie weil
es ist ein anderer blickwinkel das ist
wie gesagt sie würden vielmehr als maler
und vollständig schüler veni veni
ausgestattet wenn du mit dem moduliert
61 gut zurecht zu legen oder andere spur
auspackt
das ist zumindest nun befinden wo zum
rasch das vollständige werk das mit der
option et sa fille du kannst eigentlich
kein körperliches risiko ihn ganz blöd
beispiel wenn mieze partner hat die oper
tosca frau kraft probleme machten ja
auch mit meiner mama das ist so wie das
ist konkurrieren
das ist konkret erfahrbar gemacht dass
sie menschen klinik lernt ende mit
zunehmend weniger authentisch dass es
überhaupt gar kein problem ist ob es
dauert bis sich in der hosen- oder nimmt
wenn sie leer wird der mensch unnötig
jetzt nur dateien will sie lernt einfach
charakter und wesen und alles tun ob das
was muss ich da gibt es tatsächlich und
die erfahrung kann ich macht und liebe
aus dem grund ein glückspilz
bis heute ist wir kommen also ich bin ja
gar nicht mehr im schnitt bleiben
[Applaus]
simon kg ließ sich vor einem jahr die
brüste später auch die gebärmutter die
eierstöcke und die vagina entfernen
ich habe weder treibens herzstück von
104 gramm oder wörtlich sie und baut
doch neues jahr vielleicht ändert sich
da wieder vielleicht wird stadt
einnehmen und honig merkte ich wirklich
schwierigkeiten kam
aber ich hab schon bezahlt gemacht und
immer technika dass er sich wieder
ändern und wichtig ein objekt dass der
frau war gestorben im jahr in dem ich
als maus und das mit der frau zu
mit einer frau produkte bis über mittag
fragen mit der fall wenn ich 7 und mit
bezirksliga frauen einen namen frau
interessiert mich null
du stehst auf mallorca
die bar zusammen wenn es hormontherapie
anfangen mit 1 dreht sich dass viele
apotheken das stauende und fertig
[Musik]
karoline schulz geschlechtsanpassung
liegt bereits zwei jahre zurück
sie sei angekommen sagt sie und sieht
sich deshalb heute nicht mehr als trans
frau sie sieht sich als frau doch der
weg dahin war schwer und mit vielen
leiden gepflastert
ich habe eine freundin des puzzle quest
einerseits spieltisch und mit der jahre
style zum anderen und hat bin ich an
caroline carolinas vater hatte sich
stets gewünscht sein sohn würde endlich
eine frau finden und heiraten doch das
war für caroline gar nicht einfach denn
sie fühlte sich in ihrer rolle als man
nie wohl trotzdem wollte sie sich dem
wunsch ihres vaters nicht widersetzen
[Musik]
was machst du da noch durch drei stände
der browser
und so lernte carolina eine
gleichaltrige frau aus den philippinen
kennen wenige monate später waren die
beiden verheiratet
das ist das mini bedürfnis dass michael
lang dann plötzlich durch die andere
tätigkeit also ich bin auf jährige ich
habe die augen das bin
die manche rollen machen
das machen sie aber wissen sie was das
zeug hält
ich bin so veranlagt ich will dass ich
habe mir die freude dass ich mir also
betroffen da komme ich habe das land ist
stolz
und irgendwann ist halt mal so wie sie
jetzt von ihnen
ich kann nicht lieber was ich will was
ich bin ich auf die zähne ich darf nicht
und leben geht es mich noch mal probleme
auch noch mit t home existieren
und das kommt mir druck
teppich einen trumpf irgendeine person
text
warum bringen und warum
[Musik]
das vergisst der aronia schlimmste ich
bin sicher wenn ich die paar monate sind
1 3 0 1 0
sie braucht das irgendwas hausarbeit und
dennis vortages nachgegangen
der 1
dennis losgar
[Musik]
caroline trennte sich von ihrer familie
und lebte fortan alleine zur ex frau hat
sie seither keinen kontakt mehr
und auch der älteste sohn tut sich
schwer damit dass sein vater jetzt eine
frau ist
[Musik]
und gewiss kann
ich habe das als früher kuschte 44
minuten das leben als ballerina der
seite und wolken
sie hat aber nicht weil labor hat dass
ich das nicht ich bitte mir ist ein
aufgrund berlin älteren kurtaxe sind mir
zu schaffen
die kritik sei also sein verrufen
verleitet dazu geführt dass die probe
minute war mit einem audi datenstrom
wenn ich noch so aufmerksamkeit aber
lästig notiert wurde
es ist traurig notiert wo der fleck
familie idee das einfach ausblendet
wurde ich bei ausblendet wurde ich als
person
es hat eine wahnsinnige vorstoß löst das
nicht akzeptiert werden dass mit
barcodes werden unterstützt werden
unter extrem viel aggression ausgelöst
nico gaspari und caroline schürch
treffen sich im park der kantonsschule
wettingen
ich begrüße sie recht herzlich zur
heutigen gruppenstunden geographielehrer
pirmin suter hat caroline und nick zu
einer fragerunde eingeladen um den
schülern und schülerinnen das thema
trans identität näher zu bringen
50 entspannter verrät jörg namens nico
oder nicht betreffe die transaktion von
baden
die ausstellenden frau danke wir hatten
schwere stand gesellschaft die es
kriegen jedes eindecken eigentlich schon
mit muss große traum schule sind wir
beide schon mal als schwul beschimpft
würden sich nicht ständig schulenburg
und das ist ziemlich wenig zu messen ist
dass wir überhaupt nicht mit der
sexualität uhr ins trudeln ist dass man
ruft sexualität reduziert weil man's
man's nico sie das ganze hintergrund
endeffekt zählen die inneren werte von
menschen mitbringen
also wenn immer lieber zurück stimmt
wieso muss es dennoch ist der fall wenn
das miss erscheinungsbildes und zweitens
man ganz quasi gesellschaft erwartet
irgendwohin zu holen
immerhin schlacht wirklich auch
unterwegs wenn man würde man möge mir
zwei millionen einstellen
wird mir vorstelle wird jetzt mit seiner
frau blieb oder wirklich einmal werden
die zwei millionen bedürftige mit würde
führen dass ihr hat nicht das geschlecht
sind hier geboren wurden sind drin wenn
jetzt noch fragen ja wie fühlst du dich
als meinte dann könnte ich das nicht
beantworten so wäre ganz klar ist sein
und sagen ja und was frank lattke und s
klasse sowie der gemacht widersetzen da
die produktion wird das ist für mich
kanzlerwechsel letzten 15 jahren
interessant für sie komme die englischen
und jedes mal genau wissen
zum glück darf nicht vergessen dass eine
vielzahl verletzungen am körper sich zu
fügen
wenn man sich auch noch später dran
etwas gespürt operation noch gar nicht
eingesetzt oder bestehende dies nur zur
operation
was ist ihre persönliche frage hast du
ein penis oder überbieten
also ich weiter fußball interessiert
eigentlich auf so eine frage sollten
erhalten weil es ist mein körper es ist
nicht schlecht und ich definiere mich
nicht über mini genitalien und das ist
obwohl ich mit der gesellschaft fdp
schlägt ihnen die sensation skyline
genitalien weil kraken biologische
mensch fragt sich das genannt und was
hast du dir sicher sein
gute punkte ich verstehe es blüht
neugier and ps3 oder kpn ist rege
ich möchte aber nicht verstanden wird
das ist einfach noch die sigma dicklich
frage einfach nur noch aggressionen
auslöst es stellt mich als person
infrage stellt muss man froh und dankbar
ohne diesen team vollgemacht
[Musik]
zwei jahre nach der trennung von der
familie fühlte sich caroline wieder
bereit sich auf eine neue beziehung
einzulassen
[Musik]
klasse
carolina hat bruno walter auf einer
dating plattform im internet
kennengelernt
bis zu ihrem ersten treffen wusste bruno
allerdings nicht genau worauf er sich
eingelassen hat
weißt du überhaupt was transport etwas
was es nicht gibt dann diese kräuter was
denn alles muss durch und durch gar
nicht gewusst dass es das gibt was ist
dir erklärt hat wie ich das will ich
dass die der abgang aus der studie
vorgestellt kann mir da gar nicht gross
braucht die welt kennenlernen
nach ein paar klärenden gesprächen stand
dem glück der beiden aber nichts mehr im
weg
entschuldigung ich du mich heiraten
sie sagt ja ich mich trifft das lager
ich kann entlang was du willst du dir
die ganze zeit telefoniert kann vor der
vorbereitung mit dem zarten und so mir
irgendwer bis übers bett schlaft 67 es
auch nie seriös
und wie macht das denn
selbst ich noch nicht was die andere ist
dass ich mein bruder
das ist eine lang lang diskutiert worden
überhaupt sieht das engagement stimmte
schwul oder was weiß ich doch nicht
hallo ich lerne aber schlechte täter
wenn sie mal schlechter sein muss als
make-up ok gebrüder marx
der hat eben mit esther hericks wird von
annika red das hat die zone mit mäßiger
und mir ist es auch sie bevor ich ihn
gerne hätte ich mir in amerika ich
wollte nur frauen über ca
[Musik]
um das thema trans identität weiter zu
vertiefen trifft sich der
gymnasiallehrer pirmin suter mit ein
paar ausgewählten trans menschen in
einem lokal in wettingen schrieben sie
stücke gespannt was typisch frau des
europäischen kinos wiederum bis vom
andere als ich das gefühl ich fühl mich
erblickt regeln wir das nicht aus zell
schaftliche problem das mich so deine
stereotypen in dann kriegt ihr mit dabei
sind henry hohmann der präsident von
transgender network schweiz und die
co-präsidentin stefanie händchens sowie
die trans frau andrea von aesch die von
beruf car shows ist cologna größere
merkmalen wieso ist das wichtig für ist
das ist ja genau das nicht trennen der
marke ausmachen
und jetzt von ihr etwas machen um in die
finger mittelstufe darf man in holla was
ist dafür dass sie nach dem 10
ich finde dass du hast dich jetzt heute
morgen auch rasiert oder darf sich auch
hergerichtet warum zum wohlfühlen so wer
nicht gern gesehen
zum auf rossi
ja es gab mal dass ich mich selber
wollte man eben reich machen muss für
sich selber rechnen
das werden viele kennen das man so am
anfang von der tradition hat vieles
ausprobiert man muss sie erstmal finden
man muss ja auch seine neue rolle
irgendwo finden und da gehören eben
viele sachen dazu die man später dann
auch sein lässt ich denke man muss ja
auch der welt zeigen was man ist was man
vielleicht am anfang gar nicht so
ablesen kann auch also das bild was man
von sich ja immer schon hat mit dem
äußeren auch in einklang zu bringen
wenn man personen sieht die einen
irritieren das macht manche aggressiv
zum beispiel also das macht ja angst
nein da ist man lernt dass auch zu
akzeptieren das ist eben menschen gibt
die nicht in dein gaster reinpassen
wieso lassen
für morgen sind unsicher wirkt sind
minimal sind es geworden oder wieso das
kleid werde welt gesellschafter selber
das bild von der ideale frau hat sie all
ihren sprechenden affen die dem ideal
[Musik]
ist eine frau die vor gericht macht die
analyten fahrräder moni letzte sein dass
er gedacht habe du schreibst ja die
bühne gefahren und da ist der bildstock
sie mit bestattern volk sind
umweltminister nixe und im prinzip ich
nach gesprochen
was herrschen was löst die augen stroms
warum kommen denn sicherheit caroline so
billig
warum caroline im blick über krieg weiß
ich nicht aber sie haben sich vielleicht
sehen sie sich selber gar nicht damit
auseinandergesetzt was es eigentlich
bedeutet mann zu sein was eigentlich
bedeutet frau zu sein und dann kommt
jemand um die ecke wurde erkennt dies
ist ein man aber sieht aus wie eine frau
und nicht der ausstehende post
sobald du selber erst mal nicht
reinpasst bist du verunsichert und dann
kommt jemand der sagt ich breche durch
es ist sehr lange zeit vergangen seit
wir uns das letzte mal gesehen haben
ich vermisse dich so ganz edel wie kann
ich dir helfen dass du mit mir besser
zur kunst
mein leben lang für die runde dass ich
sein musste
alle erwarten von mir dass ich den mann
bin
der ehemann bin dein vater bin was ich
einfach machte dass ich dich nicht
verklären und du bleibst mein junior
auch wenn ich eine frau bin
der in schweigen aber jetzt macht mir
angst
ich habe mal versucht aber nun collect
mit mir in kontakt da wirklich aber da
mit dem man ganz klar um es verständlich
ruf ich schreibe mich meine kollegen
persönlich kontaktieren
oder erwerben das thema auto patriarch
dass sie weiter als frau hier oder dort
aber plötzlich auf den fotos gefunden
von die das richtig richtig in
erinnerung habe die trennung von heldt
variationen für alle steht aber dass man
sich nicht mehr alle sagen kann macht es
noch schwierig was sind denn deine
ängste mir gegenüber nicht so schwer als
meinen etwas oder jemand zu verlieren
ich hoffe auf eine reaktion von die ganz
liebe grüße tätig
[Musik]
simoncelli ist auf dem weg nach lausanne
zur letzten von drei operationen
es ist die wichtigste für ihn er wird
einen penis ersatz erhalten den
sogenannten feed
[Musik]
mit der frau ist zwischen der
bademeister und das teile ich glaube ja
schon
sie kriegen heidfeld und zu machen
dafür nico gaspari ein chirurgischer
eingriff zum penis ersatz nicht möglich
ist trifft er sich heute mit so 4q
skidoo sofia ist eine anerkannte
ethikerin die sich auf die individuelle
herstellung von penis und modellen aus
silikon spezialisiert hat diese thesen
werden ja auch mit einem
hautfreundlichen kleber befestigt an die
körper und jetzt zeige ich dir die ep
diesen sind hier mit zu vier modellen
kann man urinieren
aber auch sex haben sie werden ganz nach
den bedürfnissen der kunden maßgefertigt
man kann das so weiter machen wie
pudding und so hart machen wir ein stein
so möchtest du was anprobieren
ja da kannst du dich da hinten kurz frei
machen und wir probieren das genau sind
es dass das franz halmich mehr das ist
ja das ist raum das ist und dann von die
seite also wenn du so am urinal stehst
ja stelle durch schulleiter suchen
einfach gebaut
und irgendwo eine panne kurz gekommen
sind
als frau bin ich extrem unsicher erhöht
das mobbing ist extrem sich frauen in
die speichen jahren durch das ist mein
absoluter schutz der frau von einem
fisch noch vogel sie ich bin hübner
unterschiedliche extrem
es geht um die sicherheit auch mit dem
vorurteil oder mit einem negativen
auftakt um zu thailand riecht kann ich
liebe das ist mir klar warum das die
männer die zwar ebenfalls wie fühlst du
dich unbeschreiblich
das macht vorkommen
[Musik]
trans menschen irritieren ganz viele
also einfach von vom äußerlichen
erscheinungsbild passt man halt
vielleicht erstmal nicht so rein
vielleicht immer vielleicht nur eine
phase und was nicht reinpasst da guckt
man zweimal hin eben mann ist noch mal
irritiert vielleicht kratzt das so ein
bisschen einer oberfläche dass man auch
was eigene geschlecht nachdenkt manche
schon jetzt übernahm mit freunden im red
bull macht die kraft des gesetzes zu
es tut mir weh die haben angst dass sie
das offen lüge dass wir das nicht
vermögens oder wirken oder übersetzt
also das ist zunächst nicht ansteckend
aber ich denke wo man nachfragt öffnet
man sich schon ergibt ein bisschen was
von sich selbst wenn du dich auf machst
und lässt dann auch sachen an mich ran
über die du vielleicht bislang nicht
nachgedacht dass also insofern wer fragt
ist schon mal einen schritt weiter
ausweite kasse prüfen um zu entkommen
mit den unserer erfahrung mit dem
anderer versuchen auseinander zeit der
wünsche ist nicht der geborene helden
der natur im globe zu sehen man gut im
urteil das immer gut aber die monster
und
[Musik]
trans menschen verunsichern uns auch
heute noch manche menschen nennen sie
freaks pervers oder krank weil sie nicht
in unsere starren rollenbilder von frau
und mann passen vielleicht rütteln sie
aber auch an den säulen unserer eigenen
identität
sind wir wirklich der mann oder die frau
für die wir uns halten
trans menschen sind ein teil unserer
gesellschaft und es sind männer und
frauen wie karoline schulz simon kg und
nico gasbarri die der trans identität
ein gesicht geben
ob mit farbigen fingernägeln oder
starkem bartwuchs sie tun es mit
zuversicht im kampf gegen
gesellschaftliche vorurteile und
bürokratische hürden
karoline schulz hat ihre hürde genommen
als amtlich registrierte frau wagt sie
heute den schritt vors standesamt im
brautkleid versteht sich frau karoline
schuch wollen sie die ehe mit bruno
weiter eingehen
sie hat bucher walter wollen sie die ehe
mit caroline scherr ich eingehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
simoncelli hat die operation gut
überstanden und ist seinem bild vom
kompletten man ein stück weit näher
gekommen
caroline schild hat sich in der
zwischenzeit selbstständig gemacht und
führt gemeinsam mit ihrem
frischgebackenen ehemann einen kleinen
kiosk im dorf ihr ältester sohn hat sich
bis heute noch nicht bei ihr gemeldet
umso glücklicher ist caroline heute dass
der jüngste sohn und ihre tochter zur
hochzeit gekommen sind
[Musik]
china präsentiert wurde woanders